c'est non non wayne toussaint 4 nous
sommes le real portant par un journal
juges qui condamnent les messieurs et
dames avec pas de sens
le monde il faut pas là
je reprends le serment avant
sa part
pas de question de mentir pas moyen de
s'en sortir
y'a vraiment arriérés pire des flaques
toi y'a moyen de pizza mania 2,2 plus le
rail
le pire y a vraiment rien de bien que ça
au tard est le musicien l'audience et
reprises je vous rappelle que nous
jugeons aujourd'hui ici armand est il
exactement grand kelly pierre vassiliu
qui est inculpé de désertion
d'incitation de civils à la
désobéissance d'incitation à la morosité
en temps de crise d'incitation au
chômage d'août rage à la culture
française et de propagande étrangères
beaucoup de reproches
monsieur vassy lui de par la société
française
la société française qui maintenant va
s'exprimer par la voix de son
représentant officiel
le procureur général de la république
des proches française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françaises français belges belge
seine-maritime celle méritante 1
mon président mon bon chien monsieur
l'avocat le plus bas d'intel mesdames et
messieurs 35 kg
habillée mesdames et messieurs les jurés
public chéri mon amour bonjour ma colère
salut ma hargne et mon courroux soyez
maudits tremblay rouennais trembler car
en vérité je vous le dis
rouen comme carthage sera détruite et
pas seulement de schubert oui dieu me
tripote froid en sera détruite avant la
fin de ce siècle par la vengeance de
dieu qui n'a jamais supporté la
complicité lâché fourbe des rouennais
dans la sphère çandar et dieu hostiles
ou pas est un plat qui se mange froid
salo collabos est-ce que j'ai collaboré
avec les anglais mois par la guerre est
d'ailleurs misérable fils de tueurs de
saintes
ne voyez vous donc pas que je ne suis
pas celui ou celle que vous croyez
ce n'est pas le procureur sous la robe
austère du cas je vous raconte plus nom
qui vous parle aujourd'hui non tremblay
seine maritime et celle de marie tata je
suis la réincarnation à jamais et
maudite du terrible l'évêque cauchon
oui grotesque protosolaire constipé par
la trouvez vous pouvez trembler
c'est moi pierre pochon le dracula des
sacristies le goldorak des presbytères
pierre cauchon l'infâme évêque de
beauvais qui présida sans frémir le
cruel procès de jeanne là
n que je fis condamné pour hérésie et
sorcellerie et qui mourut ici à rouen
sous les vivats imbécile de vos grands
pères est beau grand mère jeanne laban
lorraine qui péri dans les flammes en
lançant vers dieu ce terrible cri
d'amour froid moi jamais
[Musique]
oui c'est moi pierre cauchon que de
bourgogne à paris ont surnommé l'évêque
rouge pour est ne voyez-vous pas que
j'aie lhermitte sous le bras le
sentez-vous dans coin vibrer sous la
soutane austère de l'église
la crosse auto déroulante de l'épiscopat
pour vrai et la selas dans les flammes
de l'enfer ou juste punition je me
consume en hurlant depuis plus de 500
ans
je revois jour après jour nuit après
nuit les minutes terribles de ce procès
inique et pas seulement sa belle soeur
[Rires]
ce procès inique où j'avais vendu mon
âme à l'occupant contre une assiette
anglaise plus une semaine de congés
anglaise également et un tas d'autres
choses anglaise
je ne sais plus vous n'avez qu'à lire le
livre de truman capote sur la vie de
jeanne d'arc
je revois tout le procès va commencer
jeanne la pauvre enfant la mine triste
et les joues blêmes
[Musique]
jeanne spectacle
ja jeanne la lorraine fait son entrée on
l'a fait ce soir
totalement seul infiniment seul sur un
meuble tabouret de bois elle avait le
cheveu court mais dru une triste robe de
bure tout froissé
car dans sa cellule dans sa cellule
jeanne en signe de pénitence adieu la
malheureuse dormait dans sa valise
[Rires]
au début je revois encore l'huissier m'a
corner annoncé l'ouverture des procès
mesdames et messieurs la cour la défense
bakou
natura général la royauté pierre mader
singer cochon j'entrais le dernier et
saluer mes confrères bonjour ma corner
s'allume akhdar nema gouroukoun d'emblée
je sentis peser sur mes épaules une
atmosphère lourde et pesant c'était
tellement chiant qu'on aurait dit un
film de bresson la lorraine sur son
tabouret d'infamie d'où montaient une
humble odeur de morue fumée du lait
d'une fièvre intérieur vos nom prénom
âge et qualité leur reine sofia
[Applaudissements]
18h30 sur le manuscrit royale officielle
jolie jane et non point sofia sachez
messieurs qu'en passant par la lorraine
tout le monde a le droit de m'appeler
sofia vous avez vu mais le lot vous
n'avez pas répondu à la question j'ai
dit nom prénom âge et qualité qualité
obame était simple c'est pas un métier
ça à saintes
si c'est un métier un métier très dur
des fois il faut cueillir pour y arriver
jeune lorraine vous êtes accusé
d'hérésie et de trafics frauduleux de
maladies de peau parce que l'hérésie
pelle je ne reconnais pas votre autorité
messire c'est du vieux france yeux
les oliviers mon seul juge lui seul a le
droit de me juger par nous voulons
encore cotnoir met-il en trois mots
comme ça je vous en prie ne me plaît pas
comme ça nous n'avons pas gardé les
dauphins ensemble peu me chaut lire que
vous esbly niasse ma conscience histoire
si rennes joue nuit point d'autres voies
que celle de mots gentils seigneur qui
mord de noix brutes et de groupe hors de
france
vous d'abord donné de brouter des gros
porcs de francs si vous voulez dire de
bouter langlois c'est ça jusqu'idi
langlois tu as tort de le prendre sur ce
ton ma fille cette cour est parfaitement
habilité à te juger nous sommes le
tribunal dont on parle dans le journal
qui juge qui condamne les messieurs
comme les dames
jeanne d'arc à la question du juge
d'instruction qui auriez-vous aimé être
vous avez répondu sophie loren
voulez-vous dire la cour qui est sophie
loren
c'est une ancienne prostituée 2001 vous
voulez dire unique [ __ ] milanaise
si fait mes cils
alors un jour khalfi là ça que de nous y
voyons qu'elle faisait sa quenouille
je ne vous ai pas interrompu tout à
l'heure les amours aller jusqu'au bout
alors s'il vous plaît je vous en prie où
elle a reçu un jour qu'elle filait sac
de nouilles elle entendit des voix qui
lui ordonnait de goûter les fascistes
hors d'italie et que vous montez nous
sommes en 14 131 ya pas de fascisme en
italie et votre héroïne et la même panne
et vous n'avez jamais vu les ex à la
panne est
jeanne d'arc jeanne d'arc vous affirmer
que c'est la main de dieu tu sais ce
qu'il dit bien que c'est la main de dieu
qui vibre sous l'armure austère de la
pucelle mai mais vous doutez de vous
même puisqu'à la question comment
aimeriez-vous mourir vous avez répondu
je cite avant de quitter cette vie
j'eusse aimé qu'on me cru oui comme
recrue pas comme cuites mais mes voix me
l'ont dit jeanne jeanne tu mourras cuite
qui l'eût cru jeanne d'arc avant de
faire sacrer charles vii à reims le 17
juillet 14 129 vous est livré sur la
personne du dauphin des pratiques de
débauche comme la brouette dont les
miennes ou la chevauchée bond
baudricourt et ce jusque sur la personne
même du gentil dauphin que vous disiez
défendre
reconnaissez-vous les flûtes les fêtes
vous me demandez de quoi tu as quand
même qu'on enfile ton mon client oui
aucune réponse doit jouer à cette
question je ne dirais pas plus un mot le
café l'addition s'il vous plaît savez
vous vous tenter le diable voulez vous
tenter le diable malheureuse
non mais je vais bien tenté le vent
l'eau
c'est comme il vous plaira jeanne jeanne
la cour n'en ayant pas délibéré mais ça
fait rien c'est moi qui commande un
reconnu jeanne d'arc coupable de
sorcellerie des résidents glow phobie de
pratiques que nous you feel et la
condamne à être brûlée vive à rouen sur
la place du vieux le cadet
enseignante pour moi la scène s'il vous
plaît et l'addition donc pierre vassiliu
est coupable qu'on lui coupe la tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
etonnant non
[Musique]